well if you look at the har the Harvard
Harris polls it says this is the new
issue that has overtaken inflation and
we have different ideas of how to fix it
Republicans say that uh it's like 85% of
them say that it's got 81% say the
conditions are getting worse On the
Border but only 45% of Democrats agree
with that even John fedman the
progressive Senator out of Pennsylvania
he's a Democrat he's calling this a
crisis and he said the Senate and
Congress have to deliver on this border
security situation I don't understand
why this is controversial he said he
made the best point he said look at the
numbers in December we had 300,000
encounters he said that's larger than
the city of Pittsburg and he said and
that is just one month that's right so
Brian it looks like that this is going
back to the courts again this is what
Texas is saying according to according
to Article 5 section 4 the states the
federal government has a Duty right to
protect each state from any type of
invasion and if you look at our border
and our live shots every single day at
the border it's very clear that Texas is
being invaded by several countries he's
saying that this is the governor who
used to be the Attorney General of Texas
he's saying because you have failed to
do Article 5 section 4 we're going to
use Article 1 Section 10 section clause
three to enforce that so essentially is
saying that if the federal government
refuses to protect any state we have the
right through whatever National Guard or
Texas Department of Public Safety to
defend
right listen to this so the Governor of
Oklahoma stands with him the governor of
Montana the governor of Georgia the
governor of uh of Florida they're all
saying we're with you Texas we get it
we're 100% with you now if you want to
get some momentum for any type of
legitimate Border Protection that's been
worked on now by Senator lford Senator
Murphy heading it up and you say and the
president comes out and says it is a
crisis we got to fix it if you really
want to know if they're sincere why
would anyone think the president's
sincere about it when he's doing
everything he can to cut the razor wire
that Texas is forced to do themselves
and setting in the federal government to
do it why would anyone feel good about
it when he is backing up all those
cities that have Sanctuary status now if
you look at if you look at the inverse
of what we're doing at the border for
what Texas doing at the border think
about these cities are trumping the
constitution in these Sanctuary City
status you're saying I don't care what
the federal government says we are
forbiding ice from kicking out people
who we know are here illegally from even
asking them that's also unconstitutional
but the president Stakes his uh Stakes
his uh Power and sends the courts in our
legal system after states that just want
to hold on to their sovereignty and
protect their people listen I I saw
something in the New York Post yesterday
we were up uh in New England so we did
we missed it but I picked it up today
you know the migrants are winding up in
this country with preloaded debit cards
and envelopes of cash right yeah do you
know where that money's coming from it's
coming from the United States of America
let me explain how all of us America's
taxpayers are paying for those people to
come across at Razer wire the New York
Post has his story it talks about how
the United Nations has got this uh inter
agency platform for refugees and
migrants from Venezuela and they've got
$1.6 billion doar uh to help people
reach the US Mexican border and so that
razor wire slows them down and so they
don't like that and so the United
Nations you know they've given all these
people
money to make it to the southern border
that's slowing them down so what's Joe
Biden doing he's making it easier for
them to come in and here is the
important part with the United Nations
we've talked about this for decades
who's the biggest funer of the United
Nations the United States absolutely we
pay 22% of the UN budget so keep in mind
we are financing most a lot of those
people we're financing more than any
other country on the globe those people
to come into this country illegally this
you know and for so we're going to play
the sound bite in a moment of KLA Harris
talking about how the Republicans have
made this a political thing to run on
look look what Joe Biden is doing he's
taking our taxpayer money putting it in
their pockets and saying come on to the
United States domicans want the problem
fixed finally Democrats are getting on
board and the reason is Tom homman said
it's because Fox News has been pushing
this so conservatives know about this
issue we're seeing it in our cities
you're seeing it in Texas we're seeing
it all over the South but now Democrats
are seeing it because now other channels
have to cover it because it's coming to
States like New York and it's coming to
big cities like Chicago and all these
Governors are saying we don't have the
money in fact our mayor here in New York
City is now saying federal government
give me help I need help now so now it's
an issue that everyone in our country
Democrats and Republicans are noticing
and seeing and KLA Harris is saying that
Republicans are just using this so they
can win elections no Republicans have
been screaming saying Help Us our
country is being invaded by not only
illegal immigrants and you have to foot
the bill but also by criminals that are
bringing in drugs by terrorists and Tom
homman said there are terrorists in our
country listen to what our vice
president is trying to
say some people seem fixated on Joe
Biden's age but I wanted to ask you it's
because they have nothing to run on
Katie well immigration now they're
running on too which they could actually
parti ipate in fixing right and so no
but really you know so yeah you're right
they're running on immigration because
they like having the problem so they can
they can have an issue we hope and and
and and are really trying to
compel um in particular some of the
republicans in Congress to participate
in the solution but sadly I you know we
want to fix it they want to run on it
they want to they want a political issue
to run on
in November she has so no interest in
trying to fix it she only went there
once for an hour uh went to the border
and left one of the biggest
embarrassment when you realize how
useless she was when she basically
punted when asked to take control of the
Border like Vice President Biden was
asked by Barack Obama do his credit uh
whatever the policy they had he actually
did something and for Katie KK not to
ask don't you feel responsible for the
worst disaster in American history at
the southern border is is crazy I'm not
sure if she's still with the Today Show
but uh the other thing with with uh with
uh kamla Harris is almost everything
that kamla Harris and Joe Biden can do
right now could affect the border and
help their political fortunes just
reverse the amnesty problem reverse the
parole do the remain in Mexico you don't
need Congress for that at all you don't
need any more money for that at all you
could get additional money to to uh
adjudicate quickly for people but if you
change the questions that they're asked
to the Border you can no longer come in
here and say I'm being threatened in my
country then with that's enough to stay
now you say it doesn't matter go to
another section of your country if you
don't have proof you're being pursued
you can't stay that would do something
I'm just baffled by the headline the
Republicans have nothing to run on I
mean immigration is just number one on
top of the list you got inflation you
got National Security you got what
happened in Afghanistan I mean we can
just keep going over and over and the
fact that you have a reporter right
there that is supposed to be
representing the American people and our
interest on a day-to-day basis not push
back and say what about these issues I
think is stunning well you know what
when when the Joe Biden team uh came up
with their game plan for the 2024 race
immigration migration and these images
from Fox and now they're on every
channel in every Big City because the
sanctuary cities they weren't counting
on that uh they were going to run on it
you know we're we're being inclusive uh
and now it's like the people of the
states are going please turn it off we
were all at the Boston airport yesterday
did you realize that Boston's got such a
migrant problem that just like Chicago
now they're keeping the migrants at the
airport simply because and we all know
it's freezing out there going to be
interview folks it's warm about that
later I'm Steve juy I'm Brian kilme and
I'm Angley Airhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis